you said you sit back you're talking
[Music]
well I am Jenna I've been dating Steve
for about three years now I think he
might be a little annoyed I've been
recording you and like putting them up
onto a snapchat story this is like going
to mind a little bit how long have you
been doing this for six six months are
you kidding me
there's so many funny things that he
says in his sleep every day is a
surprise what time do you want to go
tomorrow she knows that I don't use
snapchat I have one but I don't really
use it and she basically it's the
perfect crime I can't even comprehend
how some of the things he says gets into
his head if it wasn't me I'd be laughing
at it so well you want to you want to
watch them not really used to get the
photos it doesn't even sound like my
voice no time if you want to go tomorrow
I was what I say what time do you want
to go tomorrow yeah I'm always making
plans apparently forget that's all I'm
doing is me
we want to go you think at least I look
like angry and confused they're like
what is this light that is stopping me
from making plans
apparently it's trippy that's the best
word I can use to scratch it journey
yeah I'm considering this a crime right
this is like a very like modest casual
low-level crime it's like right below
jaywalking right yeah right so I got to
figure out something that's equal and
fair in terms of retaliation they still
love me right yes it's on the right
place today it'll work oh wow we should
go to the store so that we details the
pieces of furniture I'm glad that you
have zero